all right in this next question a person
asks dr. Berg what causes cataracts all
right so I want to discuss cataracts and
has to do with a person's pH their acid
alkaline levels and I talked about this
in my book on page 50 under the adrenal
gland chapter because when the adrenal
gland over acts and produces too much
cortisol that's the stress hormone what
happens is it it causes the release of a
lot of acid from the urine so when you
check the urine the person's pH is very
very very acid it's overly acid so you
may look at that and go wow the person
is too acid we need to alkalize them
that would be a big mistake because when
you lose your acids your pH then starts
becoming more alkaline so 7 is neutral
when you go above 7 you're becoming more
alkaline and when you're becoming low 7
below 7 it's more acid okay so if you're
losing all your acids your page is going
to rise upward and because the blood
operates at a very narrow band between
7.34 and 7.45 so it it it's like within
just like a very small range and if the
ph of that blood goes too high you're
going to develop something called
alkalosis now what is alkalosis that
just means that your Bloods to Lockland
and that is a condition that it happens
with adrenal gland problems and stress
so but when you measure the urine it's
excessively acid that's because you're
dumping all your acids and your body is
becoming to on the opposite and bloods
becoming too alkaline when the blood is
overly alkaline you you're going to have
a big problem with calcium calcium will
not necessarily go this doesn't even
work go in the body anymore
it goes on the tissues ok so it develops
on the nerves as neuritis like like all
the itis is implement
the heels as heel spurs on the joints is
arthritis on the bursa as bursitis
that's little sac around the joints on
the tendons is tendinitis on the eyes is
cataracts that's a calcium plaquing
because the body is too alkaline I'm
talking about the blood I mean there's
books that say you have to alkalize or
die and that's actually a myth because
you're here you're going to create a
worsening of the problems calcium
develop develops on the arteries as
plaquing on the kidneys as kidney stones
and the gall bladders gall stones on the
nerve on the left actually it could be
on the right or left as a little
twitching on the eyelid that's calcium
because the pH is too alkaline
and the calcium is not going in the bone
the muscle that's why you get cramps in
your calves work tight shoulders up here
so all of it from the Drina Glenn
overacting you can have all those
conditions could you imagine treating
each one of those separately we have to
get to the root problem the cause and so
doing that you would want to acidify the
body now how do you do that well people
that are excessively alkalyn tend to
crave acids like they might like the
what's that outside of it another cider
vinegar chips the vinegar chips they
might like carbonated water or sodas
because it is carbonic acid so they want
that what they should do is do
Pellegrino or Perrier because the
carbonated water will acidify them as
well but the best thing to do is to take
a little lemon in your water or maybe
some outside of vinegar in your water or
even cranberry all those are very acidic
and of course I recommend that in my
book on the Drina lap tur you're going
to do a drink with unsweetened cranberry
outside of vinegar and a little lemon in
some water to start to acidify you and
sometimes people say well dr. Berg why
are we trying to certify because most
people are actually too alkaline
in the blood but they're too acidic
coming out because they're losing all
their acids and when the calcium doesn't
get absorbed your breathing becomes off
so you you can't you like your can't get
enough air
you don't sleep that well you can't why
down at night because you don't have the
calcium to wine you down so there's a
lot of other problems that occur but
that's definitely one of them so this is
some extra background data help that
help I'll see you in the next video